was ist denn jetzt los es gibt gar keine
schwarzen löcher
warum es diesen hockey in diesen tagen
unser weltbild auf den kopf stellt
erfahrt ihr hier jetzt bei pixum science
fiction stephen hawking ist wohl einer
der berühmtesten physiker unserer zeit
und ist unter anderem durch seine thesen
zu schwarzen löchern weltberühmt
geworden wenn er also etwas
veröffentlicht dann hat das also gewicht
erstmal zur beruhigung so richtig
veröffentlicht hat er seine these noch
nicht sie liegt auf einem
wissenschaftlichen server auf dem thesen
zur diskussion gestellt werden dem aktiv
fördern die arbeit die logik hat
allerdings sprengkraft und stellt alle
bisherigen theorien zu schwarzen löchern
auf den kopf um was geht es also sieben
hawking macht nicht weniger als den
ereignishorizont rund um die schwarzen
löcher in frage zu stellen
dieser horizont ist quasi eine
kugelförmige grenze rund um das schwarze
loch
überschreitet man sie gibt es keine
chance auf wiederkehr alles jenseits
dieser grenze wird von dem loch
aufgezogen aufgrund der enormen
anziehungskraft ist nichts mehr
hinter dieser grenze zu sehen selbst
licht wird vom loch auf gelogen
vor zwei jahren machte sich joseph
kosinski von der university of
california in santa barbara die mühe mal
durchzurechnen
was denn eigentlich am ereignishorizont
passiert und kam auf ein erschreckendes
ergebnis als nebeneffekt der von stephen
hawking gefundenen hawking strahlung am
ereignishorizont werden dort extrem hohe
temperaturen erreicht sprich um das
schwarze loch exakt am ereignishorizont
entsteht eine feuerwand alles was sie
passiert verbrennt jetzt haben wir ein
problem
das widerspricht dermaßen den
physikalischen grundgesetze dass es
kracht so fuß die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie darauf dass jemand
der in ein gravitationsfeld fällt wie in
der nähe eines schwarzen loches genau
die gleichen phänomene erfährt wie
jemand der schwerelos im raum treibt das
ist hier ganz und gar nicht mehr der
fall
laut steve giddings er ist konnten
physiker an der university of california
ist das eine krise in der
grundlagenphysik die vielleicht einer
revolution bedarf also was tun
stephen hawking hat reagiert und einen
aufsatz geschrieben informations
erhaltung und wetterbericht für ein
schwarzes loch und dieser aufsatz der
ist vielleicht eine revolutionär sagt
nicht mehr und nicht weniger als dass es
keine schwarzen löcher gibt er räumt so
richtig auf im weltall
auch der ereignishorizont der schwarzen
löcher existiert nicht mehr
laut dieses aufsatzes stattdessen ist es
ein scheinbarer horizont hinter dem zwar
nicht um materie verschwinden sie aber
auch wieder auftauchen können er geht
davon aus dass die raumzeit um das
schwarze loch sich immer wieder ändert
also stark fluktuiert es gäbe dann keine
klare grenze und licht und materie
könnten bei gelegenheit wieder
entweichen
das wäre dann aber kein schwarzes loch
mehr
damit würde alles umgeworfen werden was
uns die physiker die letzten jahrzehnte
erklärt haben keine schwarzen löcher
kein ereignis horizont und auch kein
winziges zentrum des loches die
sogenannte singularität noch wird der
vortrag heftig diskutiert und ist keine
abgesegnete wissenschaftliche
veröffentlichung eines ist aber jetzt
schon klar nichts ist klar die physiker
bringen die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie und die
quantenphysik einfach nicht zusammen
die suche nach der physikalischen
theorie die letztlich alles erklären
kann wird also noch etwas dauern
und vielleicht werden die menschen diese
ja sogenannte gottesformel nie finden
oder was meint ihr werden wir das
naturgesetz hinter allem finden werden
wir dann wissenschaftlich beweisen
können dass es gott gibt oder genau das
gegenteil diskutiert es hier unter dem
video in den kommentaren und wenn es
euch gefallen hat las ein kostenloses
abo da mehr über schwarze löcher gibt es
übrigens in
video oder über den link in der video
beschreibung und das letzte video ein
gedankenexperiment zum thema es gibt
keine wirklichkeit das könnt ihr hier
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis dann
bleibt dran